there's two elements of trying to create
fomo there's scarcity which is a
function of the number of units and then
there is urgency which is a function of
time urgency is it doesn't matter how
many units I have the deal ends tomorrow
I'll give you an example well we have
protein it's like well you have protein
but I may have a Valentine's Day special
that is ending this week with the
scarcity component it's a function of
units there's always a way to think
about it like with the protein I thought
of flavors I was like oh just have a
limited flavor protein is going to be
here but this particular flavor will not
be or you can put scarcity in terms of
the bonuses you add so it's like I have
proteins and they're all vanilla but for
this month I'm going to be adding a free
workout or a free workout template or a
nutrition template that I'm going to add
with my protein to create these
additional value adds which no one else
is doing and then with the additional
value add you both add value and create
scarcity at the same time to urge the
person take action